enfin mimie mathy était fasciné par les
comédies musicales américaines
un temps elle a tout fait pour intégrer
le big bazar de michel fugain mais les
hasards de sa carrière artistique vont
l'entraîner dans d'autres directions
pour lui donner un jour les ailes d'un
ange gardien mais me nati n'a jamais
abandonné son rêve de chanter elle
réalise grâce à ce premier album la vie
m'a raconté sorti chez sony bmg où elle
nous propose son regard sur l'amour la
différence et la famille recomposée
des thèmes qui lui sont chers et qu'on
retrouve dans le livre aller simple pour
le bonheur de mimie mathy et benoît
gerin paru chez plon
une autobiographie croisé d'elle et de
son chef cuisinier de marie benoît
gérard où il nous propose quelques
recettes pour mitonner son bonheur
goûtez moi ce journal intime et vous
m'en direz des nouvelles
m
touché le brassard en désordre
ranger sans jamais
dérangé à mon époque mon jeune âge là la
bande dessinée la plus la plus en vogue
c'était un teint alors au départ on
adore sap
au bout d'un moment si mais ce pauvre
garçon il s'est pas c'est un garçon
c'est pas un garçon jamais tintin est
tombé amoureux jamais il a rencontré une
fille il est complètement à situer ce
pauvre garçon il est avec son chien
c'est pas possible quoi parfaite tintin
est à peu près de charisme d'un
bigorneau quoi c'est rouler une pelle un
bigorneau c'est la même chose que vous
l'êtes pas l'un tatin oui je les ai vus
souvent aux lois enfants est gelé
en top pas trop gelé vu tu sais je lai
approché la nourriture est importante la
nourriture c'est synonyme de réunions
souvent les réunions de famille c'est
c'est toute notre enfance c'est vrai que
la nourriture est un moyen de
communication un partage il se trouve
que j'avais déjà cette passion avant de
rencontrer mon mari et cette envie de
partager et je suis tombé sur un
restaurateur qui pour lequel je suis
tombé en amour vraiment venoix c
c'est les hasards de la vie c'est le
destin c'est quelqu'un de passionné
c'était important parce que c'est pas
évident de vivre avec quelqu'un de connu
qui est différente qui a fort caractère
qui n'est pas toujours très facile à
vivre je le reconnais je fais mon mea
culpa chaîne et mais c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un de passionné donc je
pense que j'aurais peut-être pas pu être
avec quelqu'un qui ne vivait pas à une
passion aussi parce que c'est pas
monsieur matiz c'est vraiment benoît
gérard et quand on a ouvert ce
restaurant
moi je me suis occupé simplement de la
décoration
c'est vraiment ce restaurant au départ
c'était peut-être le restaurant de mimie
mathy maintenant c'est vraiment on vient
manger la cuisine de benoît il est il
est respecté reconnu et je suis très
fier de mon mari je serai juste à côté
[Musique]
al
le sang
woody allen c'est quelqu'un que j'ai
j'ai pris moi aimer les premiers films
mais tout ce qui fait depuis une dizaine
d'années j'aime beaucoup j'aime cet
univers j'aime j'aime ce personnage
j'aime sa folie et son son talent
surtout et c'est vrai que je me dit des
fois je me dis peut-être qui viendra en
france qui va se mettre sur une chaîne
qui va tomber sur un épisode de la série
how this little moman allemande michael
mann mais c'est un rêve c'est un rêve de
plus il se réalisera peut-être un jour
où il ne se réalisera pas c'est pas
grave c'est important c'est de rêver
mais c'est vrai que j'aurais un coup de
fil de coppola de spielberg ou de 2,2
et allen ça ne me dérangera pas du tout
même si j'ai un accent très français je
me débrouillerai pour travailler
beaucoup et qui sait envie de monter les
gazous ce soir sur un grand écran de mes
souvenirs je regarde fils temps j'aurais
devrait connaître piaf je suis fasciné
par cette femme par son talent par cette
voie petit bout de bonne femme qui me
fascine énormément c'est vrai que j'aime
la chanson française au sens noble mais
ça m'empêche pas d'aller voir d'autres
choses j'aime fugain bien sûr j'aime le
forestier jeu je trouve que laurie fait
un boulot formidable
alors qu'elle est critiquée par tout le
monde moi je pense que ceux qui ne l'ont
pas vu en spectacle ne peuvent pas se
permettre de juger
m
livre ouvert je te sens si fragile car
je trouve que dans la chanson française
ya des belles choses bénabar c'est
magnifique c'est des gens qui avancent
qu'ils font ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
et qui qui roule tout droit grand corps
malade j'adore aussi je trouve à j'ai
découvert ça par hasard je ne
connaissais pas cet homme m'a fasciné je
trouve que c'est de la qualité c'est
parce que j'aimerais faire mais c'est ce
qui fait et qui fait très bien
un artiste qui va au bout de ce qu'il
est et qu'il ne joue pas et qui
simplement donne ce qu'il a envie de
donner ça passe forcément le public est
pas bête
mais
s'est pas moqué de moi dans mon visage
je vois des cheveux soleil je vois des
yeux bleu ciel azur je vois des kilos en
trop mais ça c'est là c'est la bonne
nourriture c'est la gourmandise
je suis gourmande de vie donc je suis
gourmande de table et de bon vin et
c'est qu'est ce que je vois d'autres
joies je vois quelques rides mais ça je
les effacerait jamais parce que je pense
que c'est les rites de la vie les les
rides qui construisent et à 60 ans si je
devais être boursouflé sans une ride
d'expression je pense que je me plairait
pas je crois que on peut faire des
petites choses j'en ferai peut-être
sûrement j'ai pas j'ai pas encore
commencé jurés mais je trouve que les
rythmes les plus petites rides sont sont
des marques de vie intéressante et toute
façon les gens nous suivent en me
suivant plus 20 ans il ya un moment ils
vont savoir g + 20 ans donc et puis je
vois je vois un sourire une moue ça
dépend et c'est vrai qu'on m'a toujours
dit que tous misé sur mon visage
et si j'ai une contrariété ça se voit
tout de suite je vois un front qui se
plisse les yeux qui deviennent el-amoud
tordu et puis si je suis heureux ça se
voit tout de suite aussi je peux pas je
peux pas cacher je peux pas cacher des
grands sentiments
plus on avance dans la vie plus bonheur
est fragile parce que les gens qu'on
aime disparaissent parce que parce qu'on
vieillit pas ce que parce que la vie
avancés avec une planète qui se dégrade
de plus en plus mais mais faut le
prendre ce bonheur il faut tout faire
pour qu'il faut l'arroser tous les jours
g bonnet
[Musique]